[Music]
stormy webster is taking control of the
camera and taking tick-tock well by
storm i love it yeah the four-year-old
daughter of kylie jenner and travis
scott totally pranked her mom when she
made her first official video on her
mom's account
[Music]
in the clip storm is seen having a blast
using a silly face distorting filter and
that's when she turns the camera over to
mom who's completely caught off guard
[Music]
mini me stormy proves she's an
influencer and prankster in the making
and proud mom kylie well she's decided
to share the funny moment with the
caption stormy's first tick tock you
excited
haley bieber hit up the comment section
summing up stormy's prank perfectly
iconic obviously she's the cool one and
while this may be stormy's first go at a
tick-tock vid it isn't the first time
she's created hilarious content with her
mom on social media check out this clip
they posted last week laughing along to
a viral tic toc sound that parodies them
are you kidding me
stormy
you look like mommy baby and back in
march we saw this relatable mom moment
when stormy crashed kylie's instagram
story okay so i know i've been mia for a
while
stormy wants to be in this
but i launched a
new lip product
lip lacquers
get out of here let me do this for two
seconds okay
that video marked kylie's long-awaited
return to social media after giving
birth to her second child stormy
graduated to big sis when kylie and
travis welcomed to their first son in
february baby number two
congratulations thank you the couple
originally named him wolf but ultimately
decided to change it and she told et all
about the switch-up why not wolf
and
what is the name wolf was never on our
list
um
it just was actually something chloe
suggested and i like don't do this
i liked the name i don't think anything
i still like
i love it i love it i like wolf i just
wasn't him
so it wasn't against anything to do with
the name it just wasn't him and i get
that you know
i get that so do we have a name no okay
we have we have some um
we have some maybe really strong options
but we haven't officially changed we
have some placeholders so before i
officially change that i just want to be
sure you're seeing that little
personality
baby boy's name still has yet to be
announced but in the meantime source
tells e.t stormy well she's loved being
a big sister
her and her brother already share a very
special bond together she's so excited
to be an older sister and watch her baby
brother grow it's so much fun the family
grows and and it's getting bigger all
the time and yeah it's really fun to see
the babies have babies and according to
our source things between kylie and
travis are the best they've ever been
they have the parenting thing down
together and are more in love than ever
before having two children has brought
them even closer as parents and as a
couple here's hoping stormy gets her mom
again or hey maybe the next prank will
involve her dad too
[Music]
you